would you like to do a split with me  right now because you're pretty good at  it I can do the split test all right I  just want this photograph that's all I  want  [Applause]  I'm getting one of these at home by the  way these are absolutely fantastic that  was pretty impressive  yeah wait so I want to see the hell of  it anyone tuning in right now  if someone's tuning in right now they're  so freakin impressed with me you want to  try this all right use your assistance  again last time okay so what do i do I  just told you here okay this is gonna be  incredible television good thing I wear  shorts today  [Applause]  hey thanks for watching be sure to click  subscribe to see even more great Conan  clips you may now return to your pirated  movies and creepy Japanese pornography